[Musique]
vous avez passé un bon dimanche
ah oui j'étais au cinéma et votre
fiancée avec mon poisson rouge
ouais ouais ça lui a plu bon du tout
qu'est-ce qu'on jouait pêcheurs
d'islande
il a pas aimé non n'a trouvé que c'était
un film raciste c'est un cadeau ce
poisson vraie vie de mon père adoptif à
vii orphelin de père non c'est mon père
adoptif qui est orpheline fils s'est
alors alors je l'adopté weemer que dit
votre vraie paix mon vrai père votre
pape il a disparu il ya longtemps il ya
dix ans
le jour où ma mère lui dit alexandrowicz
il s'appelait alexandrowicz nom jules
alors pourquoi l'appeler d'alexandre vi
parce qu'on n'a pas la mémoire des
prénoms un soir il sent bon les hymnes à
rémois voulez vous je vous narre hainard
et ma mère lui dit alexandrowicz va me
chercher du beurre pour faire la cuisine
et alors alors il n'est jamais revenu
les cafés maintenant votre mère elle a
fait la cuisine à l'huile ah oui mais
quand même ça a dû vous faire un coup
bah oui parce que je m'étais habitué au
beurre et votre frère ce qu'ils jouent
aux dames
celui qui joue au tamis les pions dans
un collège remarquez comme dit mon frère
aîné - le principal dans la vie c'est la
santé très bien presse qu'est-ce qui
fait le frère aîné il y est bon et à
part ça quel âge at-il votre frère aîné
tiburce il a 63 ans 60 363 titi a quand
même à huy à forte mais kalaja donc à
votre mère 50 ans enfin comment
peut-elle avoir un fils de 63 ans est
impossible c'est ce que je me tue les
invités depuis des années et que dit
elle elle dit rien c'est son préféré
mais les autres ne sont pas jaloux
insiste marie françoise marie françoise
vie celle qui travaille aux abattoirs à
1 en battant lé et esthéticienne à port
louis
elle a fini sur l'apprentissage qu'est
ce qu'elle a fait comme études pour sa
science po à prouver c'était ça ou les
mines et autres soeurs flec a appelé dès
lors je voudrais te flavie le masseur
flavier ma demi soeur depuis quand de
visionner un accident eh bien vous par
contre c'est comme ma soeur bah oui
celle qui épouse un capitaine on sait la
cadette les beatles c'est là qu'il est
la cadette et qu'est ce qu'il est devenu
ce capitaine garde des sceaux garde des
sceaux où ça dans un post à l'essence
sur l'autoroute alors pour en vue comme
basse et ça marche ça roule alors pour
viser comme à auzits ont fait vous savez
que je suis très ennuyé parce que j'ai
un oncle qui a pris l'autobus se connaît
des tensions qui prennent l'autobus
n'est pas en pleine poitrine
oui à penser comme ma soeur imane anane
house est combien chez vous on est onze
depuis hier ah oui une naissance sur une
visite une visite et quels is it un
berger allemand
alors vous êtes dit c'est un chien quel
chien
finalement c'est pas un chien un berger
allemand c'est pas un chien un berger
allemand est un berger allemand comme
les bergers français à
c'est un parti c'est un patron c'est ça
oui je ne savais pas le dire en allemand
alors pour en briser comme maçon ne dit
pas il est de votre famille ce berger
allemand ou un cousin germain oui alors
pour vous et comme ma soeur c'est comme
ma soeur commencé à m'énerver qu'est ce
qu'elle à votre insu rien c'est mon
frère voiture c'est votre vrai nom mon
frère a trop y comme ma soeur côté au
chômage votre surf à ma soeur mon frère
est alors il a trouvé un emploi puis
comme ma soeur et que fait-elle votre
laquelle eva celle qui a trouvé un
emploi comme votre frère et pourquoi me
dit tout sans arrêt c'est comme ma soeur
c'est comme un saumon frais à trouver du
travail
ça consiste en quoi son travail bailly
le mas i mas mais alors il est ma soeur
mais les taupes tu sais pas si tu es un
grand malade mais la 112 me parliez pas
oui pas c'est celle qui est somnambule
annoncé récemment qu'il allait plus elle
est guérie en est on
[Musique]